trois seulement à combattre le général
devenu président celui qui a paru
invincible pendant 30 ans est finalement
décédé dans un hôpital militaire où il
était soigné depuis des années hosni
moubarak n'avait jamais envisagé de
diriger le pays
il a été contraint de le faire après
l'assassinât d'anouar el sadate en 1981
où il était à ses côtés dans son rôle de
vice président
quand le président a été créé des balles
par des islamistes cet événement a
marqué son rapport avec l'exercice du
pouvoir
ces deux obsessions sécurité et
stabilité
il n'a jamais révoqué la loi d'urgence
mis en place à son arrivée qui
permettait au régime de suspendre les
libertés individuelles d' arrêter et
détenir n'importe qui sans mandat ni
accusation formelle moubarak a ensuite
été considéré comme un modérateur
précieux dans le conflit israélo
palestinien
tous les présidents américains qui se
sont succédé entre 1991 et 2011 l'ont
traité en ami
washington a versé des milliards de
dollars à son régime pour le maintenir
en selle lors de la guerre du golfe en
1991 ses troupes étaient à la tête de la
coalition arabe pour combattre saddam
hussein mais ses succès diplomatiques
ont un revers les besoins de la
population qui atteint les 80 millions
d'habitants font croissant
la pauvreté touche et la moitié des
enfants dans certaines régions du pays
le régime tente des réformes mais échoue
dans sa volonté de relancer l'économie
le régime autocratique de moubarak est
associé avec le temps à la corruption et
au népotisme en 2011 dans la foulée du
printemps arabe
la population se rebelle après
jour de manifestation monstre dans la
capitale moubarak se réjouit a quitté la
présidence dans les mois qui suivent les
islamistes sont portés au pouvoir
moubarak est accusé de complot pour
meurtre corruption et condamné
un an plus tard il le retour des
militaires au pouvoir perd né à moubarak
de retrouver sa liberté
elle est désormais très malade et que
son état se dégrade
celui qui avait toujours voulu être
perçu comme un bon père par son peuple
est mort dans la quasi indifférence
c'est sylvain desjardins radio-canada
mourir